okay big welcome to everyone who's
joining I know it takes a little while
to get every possible uh Zoo member line
uh signed up but I have to tell you all
I am so thrilled to be uh here today
with you with a rock star panel of
teachers we have so many great Educators
from across the country who are here to
share their wisdom share their expertise
with you and I'm thrilled that so many
of you are here to listen in we had over
2 000 registrations just from the us
alone and I cannot wait to get you all
kicked off so with that said let me go
ahead and dive in I just want to make
sure that we have everyone signed up
here
um and we've got a rockstar team we've
got
um Emily Norden from the Khan World
School our new partnership with ASU down
there in Phoenix serving Educators and
teachers around the world
we've got uh Brennan and Malia from the
con lab school right here in California
where I'm sitting and then from our
partner School District the School City
of Hobart in Indiana we've got Tim their
director of secondary curriculum and
Madeline their English department head
and it's such a great group that we are
thrilled thrilled thrilled to have you
all here now that being said before we
dive into all the Q a there's going to
be so much of it I want to make sure
that we get to know you a little bit
better so here we go with a little poll
just to kick things off so come ahead
and tell us about yourself tell us where
do you sit in this broader ecosystem
that is education in 20 20 30. from
teacher to instructional coach to
curriculum developer and Beyond tell us
about your grade level are you serving
younger students older students or
everyone and then finally if you had to
pick a primary subject what is your big
Focus or maybe as a former kindergarten
teacher like myself you cover everything
so let us know right in the chat we're
going to wait about three more seconds
and then we'll end the poll and share
the results
I just want to give a big shout out also
to Peggy Buffington who is the
superintendent at the city schools of
Hobart I'm in Indiana so thrilled to
have Peggy with us as well
okay so let me just end the poll and
share the results
and
um
let's see here it looks like the
whopping majority is 80 t-shirt which
totally makes sense we also have eight
percent administrators and principals
and then a bunch of teaching assistants
counselors Librarians instructional
coaches curriculum developers and more
so thank you for joining across those
different roles
then I see probably a majority or not a
majority maybe a plurality in high
school
followed by Middle School elementary
school and then a lot of folks on the
higher education end as well in adult
education which is fantastic even some
Early Childhood folks again as a former
kindergarten teacher myself I love to
see that and then finally primary
subject area obviously lots of folks
serving every possible area but
certainly a lot of folks in math science
Ela social studies and Beyond so with
all that said I know that the summer is
beckoning and I want to be respectful of
your time so let's hit the ground
running the way we're going to do this
today is we are going to take your
questions through the Q a format so if
you go to your Zoom screen and you click
that little q a button those little
speech bubbles I want you to do two
things for me number one I want you to
put your own questions in the spicier
the better the more burning um the more
important and then number two I want you
to upvote the other questions that are
really important to you and we're going
to answer those questions based on how
many votes they get to make sure that we
really answer the most important
questions so if you've got questions
about AI in the context of lesson
planning AI in the context of working
with students whatever it is put those
questions right in and just so you know
this session will be recorded it will be
shared out automatically and everyone
who's joined live which is you will be
getting not only the recording but also
a certificate of professional
development and then a chance to win a
free Year's access to conmigo our new AI
tool so with that said let's start off
with some juicy questions and I'm going
to start out with this question that we
received ahead of time which is how can
I use AI to design lesson plans I can't
tell you the number of questions we got
about this which I think speaks to the
pain point of coming up with new lesson
plans over and over again so for our
August panel if you've got a juicy
answer to that question if you tried
that out already just go ahead and raise
your hand and I will call upon you to
give that answer so Emily I saw your
hand go up feel free to unmute Emily and
share your response
okay this is actually a really cool
feature of conmigo
um that they are working on continually
developing and making more and more
robust all the time and I just was in
with one of their research people last
week and did an interview and she showed
me some of the new features that are
coming along you can put in you know I
need to develop a lesson on polynomials
I'm not a math teacher but I could put
in a lesson like I am teaching about
theme in literature right as an English
teacher and it will come up with a
lesson plan that includes
um things like a warm-up activity guided
practice it will walk you through and
give you ideas for each and every part
of a lesson all the way down to the exit
ticket at the end and when we tested it
out and she's like let's go ahead and
put in what did you you know what do you
want for a warm-up activity and it was a
math lesson that came up and she was
like look it came up with a scavenger
hunt and it totally explained the way to
do a scavenger hunt in order to engage
and get the students so you can
literally ask for a lesson plan
on any topic I think the math topics
will probably be the most robust because
that is what Khan Academy is really
known for but when it comes to those it
will not only give you just basic
objectives and things like that but it
will actually give you ideas for
activities that you can incorporate
throughout the lesson to keep things
fresh and new and so that was one of the
the prime things that I love as a
teacher that it's constantly feeding me
new ideas to help me keep my classroom
fresh
and this is sort of illustrate that I'm
going to show you what this Khan Academy
conmigo tool looks like and so sure
enough you can say create a Humanities
lesson plan you could say I really
focused on fifth grade you know uh
writing and it can build something
really great for you that being said I
don't want to make this all about
conmigo so if there are other great
tools feel free to share those out as
well but thank you so much for getting
us started let's go over to Malia Malia
what's your experience been with lesson
planning with AI
well just to kind of build off of what
Emily was saying the great thing is that
it's interactive so if it gives you this
lesson hook idea and it says like hey
you should do a scavenger hunt you can
type back and say actually we did a
scavenger hunt last week is there
anything you can suggest uh for us to do
in pairs right so you can have a
conversation with it as kind of like a
thought partner
that's awesome
um and then let's go to Madeline
Madeline what's your take here
so I have a couple examples that I've
screenshotted from when we had access
this past spring so I'm going to go
ahead
all right Madeline I think you got muted
there if you don't want to mute in one
sec but we can see your screen great
let's see if we can unmute Madeline here
okay awesome can you still hear me yeah
we hear you great wonderful okay so we
were going through a massive curriculum
change this year all of our our district
is K-12 and every single grade level of
ela had no curriculum this year and that
was uh pretty overwhelming for some of
our teachers so I worked a lot with
conmigo to see if I could find some ways
to be able to help teachers make some
resources like anticipation guides so I
was able to actually these are just some
screenshots of my chat history with Khan
Migo I had just put in I'd like to make
an anticipation guide about Civil
Disobedience and it came up with some
ideas for questions and I wanted to
actually kind of just build up of what
Malia said I wanted to make some tweaks
to what it had suggested so I asked it
can we rephrase to not contain the
critical vocabulary words I want them to
focus on the ideas rather than like
shutting down through vocabulary and it
was able to immediately tweak those
questions I've also asked it before to
lower the Lexile level of some of those
questions and you can even specify like
hey I want this to be at a Lexile level
of about 700 can you adjust the ideas to
suit that and it absolutely will
um I've also used it to then take you
know that anticipation guide I've turned
it into a worksheet from there but I've
also used it for readings so I have
examples here of you know Henry David
thoreau's Civil Disobedience I had some
anticipation questions there and I asked
it to simplify those questions so you
can see it's pretty adaptive to meet the
needs of your students and of your
particular lesson or worksheet that
you're planning
that's awesome thank you so much for
sharing that Madeline that was super
helpful
okay so now let's go to a really juicy
question and I know so many teachers are
thinking right now Beth asks how do I
make sure that students aren't
plagiarizing when writing by using AI so
we talked a little bit about the
educator side and we'll come back to
that but now let's talk about the
student side who's got thoughts there
again feel free to raise your hand as a
panelist
and then we'll see who's got some uh
deep thoughts so we'll start again with
Emily Emily what's your take here
uh this is a really tricky one and it's
one that I have to admit I'm still
working out and working through as a
high school English teacher
um I can definitely here's the thing
about AI writing
um especially when it's a new bot and
it's learning it tends to be very very
formulaic and I know that there's a
professor at ASU which is our umbrella
school that ASU Prep is under who I work
for and um he has embraced it and I've
read a lot of Articles from him he has
embraced it in his writing classroom as
being a place where students could start
with it as like a rough draft
and so but then you're gonna work with
it because the bot is going to turn back
very like you're going to see all the
transition words boom boom boom boom
boom but if you let them start with it
as a rough draft and then you teach them
the process of revision then I feel so
much more comfortable and they're
actually learning the process of
revision which I find to be the most
valuable piece of teaching writing
personally as a writing teacher I think
that's where the power is learning to
take those ideas and really hone them
and make them much stronger and more
robust than the initial bot will turn
out so I've tried to embrace it that way
okay if they turn in something but
that's just going to be a rough draft
and then you go from there I love that
um let's go to Madeline next
so I think for this one I would probably
be inclined to be a little bit more
blunt it how can we make sure that they
aren't I think the reality of the world
that we live in is they are going to use
it right
um when we had our pilot access to
conmigo this past spring I actually
caught 10 of my students using the
program incorrectly at the first go
where they were using it for more than I
had set in terms of parameters it is
pretty easy to identify as long as you
have them do some kind of like let's say
writing diagnostic at the beginning of
the year so that you're able to get a
feel for like what is this student's
voice actually like you know I I like to
tell my students like I can still read
with my human eyes and use my human
brain to tell that that's not your
writing so the key thing that I did in
my dual credit composition classes I
teach Early College writing for some of
my classes at Hobart
um the biggest thing that I said to them
is I'm going to set parameters of what
is acceptable what is going to be
allowed and so I had them use it for
brainstorming I had the music for
outlining I had a student who wanted to
write a paper about the theoretical
likelihood of nuclear warfare which is a
topic I know absolutely nothing about
and I looked in his con mego chat
history and was able to see him
brainstorming with the AI he was using
it to help him generate these better
more sophisticated ideas for his
argument that I wouldn't have been able
to provide him so the fact of the matter
is that they will but it is still pretty
accessible in terms of like that
identification Factor right you know
your students better than the bot knows
your students and so you'll be able to
see the difference pretty easily very
cool I love that Madeleine combining
sort of the best of this new technology
with the best of our uniquely sort of
human teacher intuition
um from one last thought let's go to
Malia and then we'll move on to the next
question I I've I think one of the fun
things that I've said to my students is
this is brand new so let's figure it out
together right like I've been writing
for 20 years and and you've been writing
for less but it's new to both of us
um so you tell me you know what do you
think it's good at and I'll tell you
where I think it's falling short but so
so that kind of process of we're all
figuring this out together I think has
been helpful and making it just like a
part of our classroom conversations
um but to answer the specifics of the
question I think you want to think about
writing as a process and introducing
cognigo is like part of that scaffolding
right so it at least for me and from
from for my teaching practice I'm mainly
looking working working with high school
students right so they'll pick a paper
topic they'll read books on it they'll
take notes on it right then they'll
develop their thesis statement then I'll
ask them okay parents here talk to a
friend how would your friend improve
your thesis statement okay let's throw
it in conmigo all right now what how did
conmigo suggest right and so then we
have your friends we have Kanye he goes
okay so you're the author it's your
voice right how do you want to re-craft
it so using it in that kind of like
scaffolded approach and using it with
them as opposed to kind of like
something that's that's happening you
know away and outside the classroom I
think that's where you're gonna get the
best dialogue with them over how do how
to use it in the way that that all of
you decide to gather is the way you want
to use it love those answers thank you
for the great um feedback the great sort
of framing of this big tricky question
and thanks to Beth for asking such a
powerful question to begin with
now speaking of really popular questions
um there are two questions that actually
go hand in hand the first is from Robert
which is which AI app should I be using
to help design classroom materials and
experiences because obviously there's a
whole panoply of options so I'd love to
hear people raise their hands about that
one and then Shalom who's one of our
All-Star Khan Academy ambassadors wants
to know hey what kind of conigo ever
become free for individual teachers and
their students and I would love my
amazing colleague Kristen deserbo who's
our chief academic officer to speak a
little bit to where our future is headed
so let's start with the teachers tell us
about your favorite apps in the space
and then we'll go to Kristin on the
conmigo front okay let's start this time
with Tim Tim what do you like using so
far
um I think I would just first say real
quick to piggyback on the plagiarism
conversation
uh if I may that that conversation needs
to take place right and it's a bottom
line
um it's a good question for this group
but that's a conversation that should
also be taking place within your
respective districts right with your
staff and with your students and perhaps
later we can share more on how we're
we're kind of uh approaching that
proactively this year under Dr
buffington's leadership in our district
as far as tools what I would say is you
know you can find ultimately you know AI
um Khan is not obviously the only vendor
if you will that's going to Broach this
right and they don't aim to be the only
one in the market
uh what I will tell you that our
superintendent and by all means she she
might want to speak more into this is
that you need to be wise stewards uh and
ambassadors of what you are promoting
because obviously just because students
can access things and or staff doesn't
mean that they should right and so for
us a big sell with con Migo has been you
know we're a con Academy District uh
school and so for us it's the embedded
administrative portal and access whereby
we can see what has gone on and so you
know attach EPT for example
how many students are using that per se
that aren't of age it doesn't mean
they're not going to you know use it uh
even if they're under 13 or whatever the
parameter is but for us we've broached
the con mego beta test as such to where
it allows for oversight internally on
our end to protect our staff and
students
so know what may not be the end-all
be-all nor was it designed to be but it
allows us to enter a space in a safe way
with our staff and students
hey call out Jim and then speaking of
speaking to the elephants in the room
Kristen I know that we have been known
for 15 years now as the place that
Educators can go to get free tools
anytime any anywhere
um what's the future of conmigo when it
comes to making it free
yeah so first I'm going to address the
other question which is yes yes I'll
give a little pitch for why you might
want to use conmigo to help do some of
your teacher tasks or some of the
student tasks and part of that is
because we have drafted those prompts so
when you're interacting with conmigo say
you know I want to make a lesson plan
we're sending not just you saying I want
to make a lesson plan to that that AI
we're also sending a prompt that is
about you know 250 300 words about what
makes a lesson plan and so when you're
doing that as we're seeing on the screen
right now we've said hey here's the
parts of a lesson plan it should have
objectives and standards essential
questions materials so you as the
teacher don't have to tell the model
what you want the lesson plan to look
like
we're sending that to the model along
with the information you've given to
customize it so that then that's all
done and you don't have to do as much
work on that and the same is true I
actually uh wrote The Prompt for the
writing of rubric and so I you know my
background in educational psychology
have you know a lot of thoughts and and
research about how to write good rubrics
so that's another one where we've
already put in behind the scenes what
makes a good rubric so that if you just
give it as we see here a grade and a
topic it will help you start to think
about what are the criteria and then
what are the performance standards so
anyway that's a little bit of why what
we hope we are adding to the AI space is
that that education Focus
back to the the cost issue right now the
reason if you haven't heard this the
reason that there is a cost now it's not
because we at Khan Academy have that
cost it's because actually accessing
these large language models is costing
us money so that's measured in these
things they call tokens which is about
three quarters of a word and every token
is is money that comes that goes back
and forth costs then there's a cost
associated with that what we have seen
so right now the model that we use is
what openai calls gpt4 and that's their
most recent and advanced model that when
they released four the price for three
came way down and we also see lots of
other organizations who are starting to
you know who are coming into the space
and and doing things for lower costs
so we expect in the future that yes we
will be able to offer this either at
greatly reduced cost or potentially free
for for some users
um so the the price right now is based
on our cost to access these models and
those models costs we we and everyone in
the AI space anticipate to come down
we're hoping six months a year we'll see
what those those prices do oh I love
that thank you for sharing that
backstory Kristen I'm also going to
share a little context for anyone who's
curious about these different models and
what the differences are
um but for now let's go to Peggy who
again is the superintendent
um over there in Hobart and Peggy I'd
love for you to speak to sort of these
different tools and what you're
considering for your District
well um I mean obviously when all of us
look at the genie uh let out of the
bottle I love looking at the chat
history here embracing
um and trailblazing with these
technology tools and not lagging behind
because we know our students are out
there with chat GPT as Dr Krieg alluded
to
um so I want to go back to what is it
that I love about cognego because I
think that this is the to me this is one
of the best parts of this um of this new
feature this new programming that we're
talking about with AI when our group was
piloting one of the number one things
that I heard them say is that when I'm
not available they're going to chat GPT
they're going to kind of ego um that was
that whole pilot group so I like to look
at it into
um aspects
um it's a teaching assistant and it's a
tutor right and what do I love most
about it I like the tutor
um because what do I know about kids
today with covid
um it was starting to happen pre-covered
a little bit we were getting kids to not
really engage with us in a classroom
they would hold their questions they
just didn't want to they didn't want to
participate
um they don't want to be embarrassed or
or so forth right and so they have no
problem talking to a box or their their
device uh whether it be a phone a laptop
whatever
to that point
um I was at one of my elementary schools
second and third grade sisters sitting
with their Chrome block hitting the
microphone tell me about a green snake
tell me why the snake is green and they
love interacting that way right that's
starting with your youngest kids
so
um I had a middle school student that
was not part of this pilot group yet she
knew that I had talked to her about this
new AI component and Khan Academy that
had a writing tutor right so here's what
happened she was dying to use that tutor
she was struggling with it and so I
pretended to be conmigo and I tried to
like do a zoom with her and I tried to
go back and forth with those little
questions to get her to write and before
the next the next thing before you know
it she had six paragraphs in this
beautiful mystery that she was writing
the point is is that sometimes kids just
need a little extra and they need to be
able to ask without feeling intimidated
or feeling like someone would make fun
of them and then boom it's right there
in front of them now Maddie would know
this on screen
um is that we have kids that sometimes
don't go to bed at one o'clock in the
morning and Maddie is trying to sleep to
prepare for a 7 45 class right they're
out using conmigo when their teachers
aren't available
um so to get back to the ethical moral
aspect of it digital
footprinting and citizenship really
vitally important for teachers to tell
them how they can use it what their
expectations are but you can't get past
the the fact that they've got a tutor
anytime they want it and we have to
teach them that they can go do that and
the thing that I love the most about it
they walk away confidently that they've
completed an assignment because
confidence is the number one thing right
if I can come to school and I feel like
I've done my best and I got a Little
Help from this thing on what I was
allowed to do with it I'm going to have
successful students and I think that we
can we have to sell this on that Merit
that kids are confident in their ability
because they have a tutor it's the guide
on the side that all of us have always
wanted and we could never afford it
right like wouldn't you like every kid
to have their own Aid I would
um so
um keep trying to make it affordable
Kristin because it's too good of a tool
to be closed up in a box the beauty of
Khan Academy is that it's always been
free I understand the logistics behind
all of it with the different layers the
different you know whatever but the
beauty of Khan Academy is that it's
always been free and now it has
something that will change and
revolutionize the way kids do school
because they have Instinct instantaneous
help and guess what that chat history
gives us what they've been doing right
and so we know whether it's authentic or
not authentic and they've been out on
chat GPT where they're not supposed to
be right so keep working on the price
but you sell it to the rest of your
staffs with what wouldn't everybody love
to have a teaching assistant and
wouldn't everybody love to have a tutor
for their student there's no better way
to sell this program than that okay I'm
done I love that value thank you so much
for sharing that view from the admin
perspective I think that's such a great
compliment to what our Educators have
already shared and thanks also to Robert
and Shalom for asking those really
really important questions so let's go
to another really important question
that Amy asked this may be the question
of our generation of our age which is
how can I make AI an instructional tool
instead of an adversary in my classroom
so the dark side the Light Side how do
we choose that path forward for
ourselves
um let's go to uh Tim this time Tim
what's your take
well uh I will briefly share an example
as well
so over
um the course of
over the course of uh the summer here we
were working on some curriculum things
and I was with a group of uh pardon me
while I get this pulled up I was with a
group of teachers and we were going
through oh you know how how do I work
with curriculum in a backward design
manner right whereby I think about the
standards and I think about the course
objectives but I want to deliver them in
a palpable way where it's engaging and
staff feels like this is relevant and
you know there's some things that I may
feel more comfortable with than others
right
and so basically what we did and this is
from last week or or June 27th I suppose
um is basically what we did is we said
hey so I pulled this up in chat history
by the way uh we took this notion of
cultural diffusion
um and this was one of the essential
questions uh in the curriculum map that
we were working out of and we were
talking about how to deliver this right
so you know that you have pedagogy but
then you also have instruction and
thinking about your end users
um I just put this question I copy and
pasted it as an essential question from
standards so you'll see this very much
all over the place with common core
standards as well as many of our state
standards adapted from there so what is
the role of cultural diffusion and the
spread and change of civilization
ultimately what we're talking about is
increasing depth of knowledge right
moving past rote memory what we used to
call googleable stuff right if you can
Google it then is it really relevant and
necessary for us to be doing that
together in the cherished time we have
teachers will then say well well you
know what what if this and what if that
you know I need to get their attention
I'll say hey let's just hypothetically
say you have their attention what do you
do with it right so let's say you're
teaching this lesson on cultural
diffusion and how it can spread and
change civilization I want you to check
this out so first I was like let's just
level set like what is it right and so
you can see the response there and I'm
like that's too confusing for me can you
simplify it and you can see you know
conmigo simplifies it and I say I still
don't understand help me right but quite
frankly I learn best a lot of times
through analogy okay so I said can you
just give me an analogy so they said
sure it's like a potluck dinner okay so
you're taking this abstract thing right
and you're trying to make it palpable
um and now they provide an analogy
through a potluck dinner and I'm like
that didn't help me conmigo give me
another one
so it said sure it's like music and then
look what they're doing and now I'm just
having fun so I'm like give me another
analogy right I want all my Learners in
the room I want this to stick so they're
like all right fine it's like a garden
and then you can look through here so
now I was like all right well one of the
teachers I was with as a basketball
coach and the other uh is a football
coach so I was like all right let's
think Sports so I said give me a sports
analogy to explain cultural diffusion so
they give me well it's like the game of
soccer
so then I'm like all right what about
like pop culture so then they explain
cultural diffusion to us through an
analogy of uh of the world of fashion so
you get the point this literally you can
see time stamps was minutes okay and
then I said this all right fine cognigo
thanks for the analogies how can I
assess my students on whether they know
the role of cultural diffusion and the
spread and how it changes civilization
and you can see that it gives me
examples okay this is literally minutes
then I say can you give me an example of
the role play activity because I kind of
like that right like I kind of like the
role play activity but I don't know how
to do that look what it does sure it
even names it the cultural exchange of
uh fair and it gives an objective
materials needed Etc so this is a simple
example of minutes right how this can
partner with you
um to create relevant engaging
meaningful instruction that increases
depth and knowledge
thank you so much Stephen again I really
appreciate that visual example because
it really drives home what's happening
here
um Madeline what's your take on this big
question sort of AI as adversary or as
instructional support sure so I think it
has everything to do with the framework
that you use right
um you do have to do a lot of front
loading with this
um one thing that I noticed come up in
the chat uh it was just a question that
I saw briefly as I was scrolling through
was about Shakespeare right obviously
some of these greater known figures and
their Works they are public domain and
so Khan Migo is able to interact with
those pretty well if you're looking for
it with any AI program an easy way to
circumvent that to an extent so that
it's a resource but it's not you know
doing the work for kids so to speak is
with those more like public domain you
know Classics and what have you
um
I would recommend doing synthesis-based
prompts with those give them something
that is more current to pair with that
classic work and then that way it will
be able to yes help them find some of
the information they might need or you
know circumvent part of your prompt for
the the classic element but they are
still going to have to make those
connections to something else on their
own so even I think the person who had
typed that in the chat was a college
professor I get that essays are still by
and large the method of assessment there
that's a really great way to get around
that another fun thing that you can do
with those types of text I'll use my own
classroom as an example my freshman had
access to this uh through
um their math class because I piloted
this with my juniors we had just
finished Romeo and Juliet and I had my
students debate with Romeo Montague
because we one of the biggest questions
in our classroom was did Romeo actually
love Juliet was that genuine love or was
that teenage infatuation and so they
debated with the AI who role played as
Romeo and Romeo argued with them and he
he stood for his passionate love and and
many of them based on the quality of
their debate they were able to get Romeo
to cave and agree you know what you're
right maybe I didn't actually love
Juliet in the way that you would Define
it today but let's explore how history
was different and so it added some
different levels to my lesson and the
kids were having such a great time
um and some of them were able to vent
some very valid frustration at Romeo's
Behavior Uh and and so they they left
the lesson enjoying the text and
engaging with the text in a way that's
just different than what we used to do
we we do have to adjust and adapt and
the more front loading you do the better
of that thank you so much for sharing
Madeline and then last but not least
Emily this classic question Friend or
Foe where do you stand
um I think we need to embrace it as a
friend and use it and I think one of the
keys for that in my mind is transparency
I'll keep my answer fairly short if you
are using it as a teacher share that
like
you know Tim used a great example and he
showed at like show that share that with
your students project it up show them
what you're doing Empower them to be
able to use it for effective ways
themselves that way it's an open thing
in your classroom and you don't have to
feel like oh are they trying to get
around are they no they know when you're
using it you can know when they're using
it I know with our students this last
semester who were piloting it as well
um they would flat out tell us when they
would turn in some type of assessment
they would say I use conmigo to help me
with this and it was really helpful to
know that and to see that they could be
transparent and we can be transparent
and then it truly does become a friend
and I loved Madeleine's ideas about just
being able to look at synthesis
questions deeper level questions that
and different ways of creating
assessments that will allow
demonstration to move beyond what Khan
Migo might project for them but I think
transparency is key for everybody to
embrace it to know that it's their
everybody is having the chance to use it
and chat history can really help you
kind of see what your students are doing
on the back end in case you do have
questions
that's a great call out Emily I love
that idea of like bringing your students
along with you on this journey as
opposed to like having this too formal
divide okay thank you Amy for that
really important question now David's
got a really juicy question that I think
speaks to this changing world of norms
that we're entering into what are the
best tips in terms of students using AI
for research so we're talking about this
idea of going back and forth with the AI
bot how do they cite these conversations
with AI if anyone has sort of had to
think about that in the context of your
own classrooms how do you help students
think about sourcing this information
citing it let's go to Madeline
sorry I feel like I've been raising my
hand a lot for this but I literally used
conmigo with a rhetoric and argument
early college class so this is kind of
perfect
um what I had my students do is I
encourage them to use conmigo as
brainstorming but the analogy that I
used because it is it is technically
public domain but it's public like chat
GPT the the content from it is
considered public domain but it is
taking from other sources and other
locations I compared it for students to
Wikipedia right we tell our students
pretty regularly that even though
Wikipedia is widely edited and most of
the information should be pretty good
um and pretty trustworthy we wouldn't
use Wikipedia as a source for our paper
right that's not something that would
meet a certain standard of credibility
so I encourage them to use it more so in
that brainstorming phase to help them
build counter claims to help them
explore perspectives that went beyond
their own prior knowledge but then they
were responsible for finding sources
that would support those claims so
really it's it's kind of no different
than if they were to discuss the The
Prompt with you or with a classmate do a
think pair share it's very similar to
that where they would still have to do
that leg work it's just meant to be a
supplement in that brainstorming part of
the research process
Thank you Madeline
okay thanks for the question David and
now Frank asked a really big question
which basically speaks to what I was
sort of getting out of the chat is like
you know throughout human history
whether you were a princeling in the
medieval times or Bill Gates kids today
you have an access to personal tutors
and people there to support you whereas
the average student even today may have
be one of 30 students in your class and
you may have 150 other students in your
other periods
how do we actually get to this Holy
Grail of a personal tutor for each
student
does anyone on this uh call have a
thought about how do we actually get
there how do we actualize that vision
again feel free to raise your hand
panelists if you have thought Krista I
know you've been thinking about this a
lot go for it
absolutely so this is where we try to
economy go to go so we know there are
things that good tutors do there's
actually moves that good tutors make
that research has said hey here are the
things here's where a good tutor asks
for more information here's where they
make a leading question here's where
they give a hint here's where they the
students getting frustrated and you
actually give them a little more
information all of those are things that
we know are things that good to good
human tutors do
and so what we want to think about is
how can we make these other tutors that
are artificially intelligent do things
like those human tutors and that's what
we've been trying to do and working on
we're not certainly we're never going to
replace humans but we can take some of
the things that we know humans do that
we think that technology could be good
for and and move them in so there's a
question I was just starting to answer
in the Q a but I'll do it here which is
what's the difference between chat GPT
and conmigo
um and so one of the things chat GPT you
are just interacting with what we what I
call the raw large language model so if
you ask it a question it's going to just
give you the answer
with conmigo we have given conmigo
instructions about how to act like a
tutor so don't give the students the
answer in fact walk this if it's a math
problem walk them through the steps uh
think about what ask the student what
what do they think the first step should
be those kinds of things so and in the
in the math space I think it acts as an
individual tutor when you're working on
a math problem it knows what that
problem is and starts doing some of
those things that human tutors do to
walk students through those so it's as
they're engaged in solving the problems
the tutors there like a human tutor
would be and saying those things and
we've heard a lot about writing on this
call so far and in the same way a human
tutor I was a Writing Center tutor in my
undergrad years
and would walk through you know starting
with the the big things like what's your
thesis then thinking about organization
station and then think you know you
don't start off with the grammar and
spelling mistakes
um and so we are also starting to think
about you know how we can do some
writing feedback in those ways but it's
certainly right now is able to be able
to brainstorm with you think about ideas
go back and forth on those kinds of
things so basically the summary is we're
trying to look at things that human
Shooters do and build them into the uh
the tutor experience so that it the the
AI acts in ways that humans might
I love that so not Reinventing will but
taking the best practices of the last
two Millennia and applying them for
every student Brennan any thoughts there
yeah I mean Christian really Nails it I
mean and and I'll just kind of build off
that because you know and my work as
um as a college counselor we you know
this really is about leveling the
playing field right this tools like this
really have the power to
um work with all students to do
brainstorming and things like that so
you know I I work individually with kids
on college essays and help them
brainstorm brainstorm topics but
um the the tool and the way students can
interact with it is just so powerful as
they start to think through like okay
what's my story and what what's what do
I what do I have to share and and it's
this back and forth that a student might
have with a tutor
um or a
um a counselor that that can really
um it's not writing the story for them
but it's um it's helping them think
through kind of um what in their
background and and
um I think especially in this moment
we're having
um is important right like how how do
things students think about identity and
how can they share that
um and and I I've been using the craft a
story for the college essay I know
you're in the the college admissions
section but I've been using the craft a
story
um in terms of brainstorming in terms of
research
um the the college the navigating
College admission is is beyond me I mean
I it's it's amazing to see
um how deep students can get into kind
of okay I'm interested in a college or a
career or or whatever it might be that
is
um you know I'm interested in a college
where I can
um study black holes and play rugby and
um has a strong sense of community and
is
um in the Midwest and I mean and it
provides a list that it exactly like I
would have provided and better because
it can really dial in and and it's the
whole kind of trust but verify right
like I I as a counselor it makes the
same mistakes I might make right like I
as a counselor might tell a student oh
you know you really want to study
um
um molecular biology you should look at
this school and they come back to me two
weeks later and say
um that school doesn't even have
molecular biology right because they've
done away with their program or whatever
it might be and so um they run into the
same thing right that we're teaching
them to be curious we're teaching them
to be researchers and the ways they can
engage with a tutor or a tool like this
is just um is is pretty astounding to me
that's awesome Brandon thank you for
sharing that and then one last response
from relia and I'll move on to the other
side of the humanities versus stem
Spectrum
Force both what Chris and Brennan said
like the greatest two uses for me have
been conmigo's ability to be a Time
Saver and to be like a creativity tool
right and so as Kristin said with a Time
Saver she's like when I put in a
question there there's additionally if I
understood you correctly like an entire
prompt that goes with my question
because sometimes something will just
come up and we'll have this awesome
opportunity to bring this person into
class or to do this activity right but I
don't have like so many hours to sit
down and okay now I got to make the the
rubric for that activity now I got to
make that this I mean it takes a lot of
time right but I can very quickly in
conmigo kind of in my language in my
speak be like I need to make a rubric
this is kind of how I want it can you
help me right and so then it's gonna
give me back information that is helpful
that is accurate that I can still modify
but as opposed to me just sitting down
on my own or me going and putting like
the raw thing into like a raw up large
language model
um this is going to help me make
effective use of my time for these these
things that often are time intensive and
are important um so so it's helpful in
that way and then as Brennan said it's
just like a creativity tool and so like
I like to think about it as especially
with the with the stories and and with
the other things of like you know how
can this help me explore how can this
help me think and and how can I practice
that with my Learners in class and so
that we're all kind of doing this
together
um to explore together
on that Maria thank you now I know we've
been talking a lot about Humanities and
I love Humanities as someone is married
to a PhD in labor history but I will
tell you that there are a lot of folks
on this line who are curious about math
and science on the other end of that
Spectrum so Rebecca says what are some
great ways to incorporate AI with
teaching math and science
so to focus on this line have some
thoughts for our friends on that end of
the discipline Spectrum
you know we've got a lot of folks in the
humanities
Kristin anything you want to share based
on some of the best practices that we've
been crafting
yeah I was going to give a teacher space
if they want to jump into but feel free
to raise your hands if you have some
things to say so a couple of things that
we know uh in in math and then I'll talk
about science so in math we know that
um that practice is a key component of
improving math skills and developing
fluency and that's a lot of what at Khan
Academy we you know have traditionally
had I was just visiting a classroom who
was teaching college algebra in a title
one high school and what happens is
they're kind of doing their independent
work their independent practice and they
get stuck and so they sit there with
their hand raised and there's one
teacher and there's 30 kids as you all
know and they're you know the T the
students sitting there as if you can see
my video I'm showing you know their
hands getting tired they're like
propping it up with their other hand
waiting for the teacher and no learning
is happening for them as they're waiting
for this well as they were working with
conmigo that the teacher would just say
hey check in with convigo see if convigo
can help you and they could you know
that they were able then to get that
little extra help they need because we
know when when people are learning if
things are too easy they're probably not
learning because they don't they're fine
and if they're too hard they're getting
frustrated but if you've got them on
that learning Edge they just need a
little bit of help to get that that over
the hump to get that one thing they're
confused about and then they can keep
going and so I think in math that that's
a key place where kanmigo is really
helpful
um and can really help students kind of
move forward with what they're doing and
you can do that as we're seeing on the
screen here in the tutor me section so
even if you're not working on Khan
Academy problems you can do that in this
space here and where things are
the other thing about science that I'll
add is one of the things that I love
about Sal's videos in science is their
sense of wonder and the sense of like oh
my gosh that's so cool and so
um Jeremy if you scroll down actually on
the activities page
um to the uh what am I looking for here
no go go back uh ignite your curiosity
um and you can just type in a topic here
like biology for example
um and it will just share it's gonna you
know give you a couple ideas and
um just some questions that are like oh
yeah how do our bodies fight off germs
and viruses or what is the smallest
living organism on Earth or just these
questions that just can spark your
curiosity
um and so I think that's another good
way to kind of hook kids in um and get
folks excited there's and the final
thing I'll say is the the lesson hooks
in the teacher section is a good place
if you're like what can I do for the
five minutes at the beginning of class
that maybe activates prior knowledge and
Sparks curiosity that's a great place to
just get some new ideas even if you've
been teaching for a long time sometimes
it's you know fresh ideas are good
um you give them a a topic and it'll
give you uh two potential things you can
do with hooks and then if you don't like
those you can ask them to make them more
exciting or you can ask them to make
sure they include uh baseball or you
know whatever the thing is that that
your students are are interested in so
there's some thoughts for me cool cool
thank you so much for sharing that
Kristen I know all of our uh many Math
and Science Educators out there excited
to see that
um I know we're down to about our final
10 minutes so I want to end with maybe
one or two really juicy questions
um that I think people are excited about
so
um let's start with this question here
um from Antonio I think Antonio speaks
to something which is even more
important than like the individual
prompt which is how would you use AI to
track a student's progress through the
school year and Beyond so again our goal
as Educators is just to make this one
lesson fun it's so that they walk out of
our classrooms at the end of the year
more empowered to be
um you know great members of our society
great Citizens Great everything that we
Aspire for how can we use AI to help
with that more long-term progress
um Tim is a thought let's go inside with
Tim
yeah I'll just start the conversation
rolling not that I have all the answers
to that but what I would say is
this entire uh narrative that we're
exploring together I think it really
hinges on
you know what what how do you measure
learning right and we know that there's
metrics in place that are quantitative
that you're trying to use you know
metrics to evaluate growth right
achievement things of that nature
I would start the conversation by saying
what I Envision is the ways in which
conmigo for instance chat history inside
of Khan Academy
Etc
and demonstrate student thinking
ultimately I think about the work of
Chris tavani for example and Chris
tavani basically said
um
you know why do we have a worksheet why
do we have homework like what is that to
demonstrate work uh what if we were to
replace a worksheet with the think sheet
isn't that really what we want to see is
thinking and so I think the the question
that we should be asking here is how can
I utilize this tool this resource this
portal
to track to have discourse with
what thinking on the page looks like and
by the page obviously I mean the screen
in some sense and then follow that up
with qualitative metrics
um and so I think when you look at mixed
methods approaches this is a whole new
layer to that conversation
I love that Tim thank you next to
Madeline
so one of my favorite activities that I
kind of uncovered using conmigo uh
during the course of our pilot
was a subsection of the practice debate
activity so I had it's broken down for
those that haven't seen it before by
Middle School level debate topics and
then High School level debate topics I
think Jeremy's showing it to you now
um so my students at the secondary level
like the upper secondary level they were
obviously using the high school one
and I had just taught a mini lesson on
logical fallacies right and so I paused
the just basic practicing with the tool
that we had been doing before and I I
told my students I want you to try
engaging with the AI in this debate
using as many logical fallacies as
possible I want you to argue as badly as
you can right and then one of my
students is the one who actually had the
idea initially she changed the entire
lesson she asked the AI what could I
have done better
and Khan mego was giving each of my
students when I had them ask that
question
individualized feedback about how they
could have engaged in the conversation
in a more respectful way so what I had
my students do to demonstrate
understanding was I gave them a kind of
exit ticket free right prompt where I
had them explore the feedback they were
given and did they agree or disagree
with it and what could they do a better
job of the next time they engaged with
the program so again it's that I thought
that was a great example and it was you
know student directed they were the ones
who came up with the idea in the first
place I can't take the credit for that
but
I loved how it gave them the opportunity
to not just take the feedback and copy
and paste it and just kind of move on it
wasn't this like Standalone Island it
was a part of a bigger lesson in the
quality of their own writing so there's
ways that you can do that by using it it
like conmigo or chat gbt or whatever
program as a part of the lesson but then
have them think bigger and you can have
them track their own progress over time
because that's that's the world we're
moving towards right these kids are
going to have access to so much passive
knowledge uh where they don't have to do
a lot of the legwork asking them to do
that reflection for themselves is going
to be so critical to keep them engaged
oh great I know you know we're down to
just a couple minutes left so I just
want to go to the panelists one last
time and this may go down as one of the
most important summaries in the history
of American Education in the sense that
this was the summer that we as Educators
had a chance to get ready for what's
what's to come in the fall and I know
that
um there's so much unknown still but if
you had any words of wisdom to share
with your fellow Educators out there in
terms of how you're grappling with it
yourself how you'd want them to be
thinking about it or framing it up in
their minds any final things that you
want to share with our incredible
colleagues Across the Nation let's go to
Brandon
yeah I would just say I mean as with
everything in education we just need to
model the process right we need to set
expectations
um and be clear about expectations and
and discuss those with our students and
and model the process as Learners of
this new tool instead of instead of
pushing it away how do we incorporate it
into the work we're doing to to again
kind of be creative and and be more
efficient and be better learners all
that go to Peggy
um I couldn't agree more modeling is
really important I think one of the
things that's really important for all
Educators is that I mean what prevents
them from doing anything new is fear
right and so we have to do some
hand-holding and we have to let them dip
their toes in the water and so I would
say that to all my colleagues I mean
we're going to start off with a
hand-holding session here not to be
afraid of it and and then in the
teacher's mind why should I use this
what are the benefits and we have to be
able to show them some wins right off
the bat but as we know in the
progression of trailblazing Educators
that go out there and give it everything
that they have
they're going to start off with
replacement right I mean like that is
going to be the first thing that they do
because they're looking for something
that will make life a little easier for
them and once you have them hooked with
that I think that's it right
um so I mean like what would my
objective be and Maddie's going to be
helping me start the school year with
this I want them to start off with a
small win with teacher resource and I
want them to have a small win with being
able to maybe do some debate and
discourse with their students to be able
to see what AI can do and then we
continuously just model what those good
strategies are as we go forward and let
them see it's nothing to be afraid about
it is really going to make learning so
much more exciting and so that's my uh
My Philosophy here because I'm just
going to tell you that it will start off
as replacement but then you can see as
Maddie and all of our colleagues have
done now it's in a whole different realm
so we have to start them on the same
foot
thank you so much Peggy and then finally
Kristen some last words of wisdom for
our amazing Educators sure so apart from
Fear I think there can also be cynicism
I've been in the education technology
space for about 20 years and I know that
sometimes there's all this hype and it
never really comes to pass I am
optimistic about what this new
technology what this AI can do
um but I think we also need to you know
recognize that there's been a lot of
Promise in the past that hasn't come to
fruition and we should be uh hopeful but
also uh just be clear that we know the
value of humans we know the value of
teachers and much of that is not going
to be replaced by the technology and so
making sure that as we as as you as
teachers and the teachers you work with
understand the the value that they bring
and how technology can just help them
improve the value that they have I think
is a good way to approach us as well
that is an awesome note to end on
Kristin is that AI is not this weird
alien thing but it was built by humans
to serve our human needs based on what
we've learned from our own expertise so
I think that's a very hopeful note to
conclude our session on I want to thank
everyone for joining I want to thank two
groups in particular first of all this
incredible group of panelists from all
across the country who's on the front
lines of all this please please please
come to the Q a I know it's a little
awkward but send them a little love let
these folks know that you appreciate
them giving up an hour of their summer
to share what they've learned and then
for the second group just a massive
thank you to you
I mean as an educator who craved his
summer vacations more than anything when
I was a kindergarten teacher the fact
that you invested this hour with us
thinking about making the fall even more
powerful for your own students that is
sort of the greatest representation of
what Educators do which is build a
greater future for us all so thank you
for your incredible investment your time
and your expertise here's wishing you a
beautiful rest of the summer cheers
everyone